[Music]
yeah good the more guys had a lot of the
[Music]
United
[Music]
if you want to be an honorary Korean you
have to know how to make the best japa
guty ever greetings salutations man we
just we just coming out with videos now
huh I'm losing it often losing it well
as you guys know by now parasite the
film directed by Poland you know one of
my favorite directors of all time has
now popularized one of my favorite
ghetto at home dishes you know what's
interesting about this dish is that this
dish is something that I've been eating
for a very very long time but a lot of
people don't know about Japanese when
they saw it on the film people started
freaking out about the dish and I got to
tell you when people are making this no
you're not making it wrong you're not
making it right you can tell every
person that's done a tutorial on this
online has never really ate this dish
before because you're kind of just doing
it the way that you think it's supposed
to be done or someone told you how
you're supposed to do it but you're all
[ __ ] wrong you don't just eat jaffa
gude man it's a lifestyle you have to
lust to live it amen okay let me tell
you [ __ ] something this right here
this this right here is titty by choppa
gaudium see well let's talk about what
we're going to use for the Chop agouti
hold on a second
so essentially what Chop agouti is right
it's two instant pack ramens now this
isn't like the regular ramen that you
get we're not talking about like top
ramen we're talking about Korean la
Myung goody comes from nobody
Rudy Gudda Gudda Gudda rockin everywhere
nobody is basically a spicy seafood la
mina what is trying to imitate is this
disco jumbo jumbo is basically a spicy
noodle dish that's like a fusion of like
Chinese Korean food then we have tapa
Getty which is the tapa part of the guty
that's one of my favorite things I've
ever put in my mouth - penis
okay I'm seriously losing my [ __ ]
mind but joppa Getty is an instant
noodle dish as well based off this dish
called onion which is a Korean Chinese
fusion dish once again that's based off
the Chinese version of I think Todd's
ambien or something like that now these
two are the traditional instant noodles
that you'll use for japa getti but I'm
gonna flip it up a little bit
BAM [ __ ]
I don't want you guys to use nobody in
this dish yeah it's called jab boo
goodie and you need nobody the only
thing is is when you use nobody you
actually don't get a lot of that spicy
seafood noodle flavor because the tapa
Getty sauce is actually very very
overpowering or powering in a good way
because I should British specifically in
this pack there is a special ingredient
they have a spicy oil that actually
coats the noodles and you can taste the
spice and the heat through the choppa
Getty sauce and you only need a couple
of more ingredients to really make this
dish pop so how about I just shut the
[ __ ] up and just start cooking huh well
of course first things first my friends
we are going to fill a medium pot filled
with water not too much water because
we're actually not gonna use all of it
then you're going to take that water if
we're gonna get that water boiling hot
now when you open up these packs of
ramen you're going to notice that the
jumbled onion and the choppa Getti
lamien are actually different noodles
and that's okay that's how it's supposed
to be then they're gonna be different
and that's totally fine now in those two
packages you're gonna notice that
there's going to be two seasoning packs
two dried vegetable packs and two oil
packs now when the water comes to a boil
take the jump on line and seasoning pack
and only use about half of it we
actually don't need all of it for this
recipe after you're done with that throw
in both dried vegetables from both
packets into the water now while that's
still hot and boiling the way I want you
to get a small skillet or a small pen
melt some butter and what we're going to
do is to start sautéing some onions now
these onions are going to be delicious
in this dish you could have it diced as
small as you want but I like it
relatively small because I kind of want
it to melt away some people like to keep
it bigger to add a little texture which
is perfectly fine also what I like to do
with the other half of the seasoning I
actually like to use it as salt to
season the onions instead of throwing it
away so while that's going throw in your
couple of packs of ramen into the broth
and start cooking away while I was
cooking and I realized that I didn't put
enough water and which is perfectly fine
it's actually better to have less water
than not enough so I decided to add like
another 1/2 cup or so of water then when
I'm done with the noodles - the doneness
that I like I'm gonna take the noodles
put it into a strainer and then save the
broth
then we're gonna dump the noodles back
into the pot and then this is where
we're going to create the magic my
friends now before we add the seasoning
packs we're gonna take those slightly
caramelized onions and put it into the
noodles first now we're going to add all
of the top of goody powder into it you
don't need to save any of the season for
this one cuz we're gonna need it for the
sauce and we're gonna dump all the oils
first we'll put the top of goody one
then we're going to put that delicious
spicy chili oil in and the nobody
lineman doesn't actually have this so
this is gonna be the huge hitter in this
dish now the reason why we save the
broth is because the noodles are going
to be really really dry and we're
actually going to need that flavored
seafood broth to thicken it up with all
the starch in that liquid so you're
gonna add as you go and depending on how
watery or how thick you want your sauce
you're just gonna keep adding and adding
and stirring and stirring and stirring
until you get something that looks
relatively like this now up until this
point everything is preference if you
like its sauce year you like a little
drier if you want to add a little bit of
the extra seasoning to make it a little
spicier then be my guest and how salty
it is is going to depend on how much of
that water that you had in the beginning
when you created the broth but when
you're done the dish it looks something
like this and my friends you are going
to be the happiest person alive trust me
now my favorite part about doing this
time to eat baby ooh your japa buddy
when you have this should taste like the
cha-cha Tony but it should have that
heat and that kick and that that that
charred a spicy oil flavor that you get
from that jumpin packet that's the
biggest difference that you're gonna get
compared to the nobody that's spiced oil
oh right here though you're going taste
it obviously in the parasite film you
see pieces of steak in there and that's
what makes it and I'm done where you add
the you know the steak pieces but we on
quarantine [ __ ] and I got saved that
meat for some other time you feel me ha
ha who you got those buttery little
pieces of onions in there and by the way
be could to witness with your onions
because the cha-cha Tony flavor and the
spice jumpin packet has a lot a lot of
flavor in there so you want to taste
those onions oh God
hmm remember have you wanted a little
spicier to use the rest of that package
I saved about a third of the the spice
mix so like I make sure I get that heat
through ooh
this right here oh and by the way make
sure that you eat this with some kimchi
baby hmm
I actually was introduced
there's my my buddy edrick he's a guy
that your secret society with he told me
about Java Cody and um I kind of fell in
love with they ever since this is high
in calorie by the way so this is
probably gonna be my only meal a day to
mind some protein that meat later but oh
well I know a lot of you out there if
you haven't had like Korean ramyun
Korean ramen is something else it's not
just your typical regular packet ramen
you really can add your own flair to
this and make this like a really decent
meal like I'm not even playing like yo
somebody charged me for this so I don't
have to do all this work I'll buy it oh
yeah oh yeah you guys try this at home
and you can get your hands on these
packets of ramen let me know what you
think of remember just because I make it
this way it doesn't mean that you can't
make it a different way okay one more
bite now well guys
we'll see you next time happy quarantine
and oh no um